hallo ich in meiner lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen let's
play und zwar feed the beast oder
feedback gespielt weil wir das zusammen
also ich mach das zusammen mit 10
hallo hallo wir hatten uns das jetzt
einfach ausgesucht bzw war es eigentlich
eine spontane idee und zwar habe ich das
einfach mal so gefunden und da das noch
fast niemand gemacht hat beziehungsweise
sehr sehr weniger als gedacht wir
probieren es doch einfach mal was so ein
mod pack und wenn ich mal drücke seht
ihr hier schon hier sind 73 seiten mit
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz vielen
sachen die neue hinzugefügt wurden unter
anderem redstone sachen neue blöcke neue
biome neue mops alles alles möglich also
ganz ganz ganz ganz viele neue optionen
und wir hatten jetzt erst mal gedacht
dass wir das zusammen machen und das
jetzt in der ersten folge hier erst mal
hier und das wenn der ersten folge erst
mal damit beschäftigen dass wir so ein
paar rohstoffe finden wie zum beispiel
eisen und und ein paar sachen machen und
dann in der zweiten folge und so werden
wir uns damit der ihm mit der mode so
richtig beschäftigen sage ich mal das
heißt richtig umgucken und ein bisschen
damit halt wie schon gesagt beschäftigen
und da wäre es halt total gibt wenn wir
uns in die kommentare schreiben können
wenn ihr das eventuell kennt also hier
sind echt viele mods drin enthalten da
könnt ihr einfach ich habe den linken
die beschreibung gepackt und könnt ihr
doch einfach gucken welche modelle drin
sind als wenn ihr bei irgendwelchen mods
bescheid wisst könnt ihr uns dadurch ein
bisschen weiter helfen sonst allgemein
mit dieser mod uns ein bisschen das
erläutern wie das so alles genau
funktioniert wenn ihr da mehr ist weil
wir sind da gerade noch relative knoops
drin
richtig ist kein genug für rotwild da
hat er natürlich alle tipps alle hilfen
von euch sind sehr sehr gern gesehen
komm mal kurz mit ihr unter ich weiß
auch gar nicht dass jetzt ein neues herz
oder das rheingold nee das ist neu
das ist es irgendwie sowas komisches
also ich hab das zwecks pd kräftig speck
drin allerdings ein paar blöcke sind
dann halt nochmal default weil wegen
keine ahnung die wurden halt nicht fix
ist nicht darauf ausgelegt dass man hier
mit dem spielen kann ist er unser spawn
war relativ genau hier das weiß auch
noch ja und hier ist recktenwald auf
direkt zum gletscherdorf da hinten ist
ein cooles neues bio mit zu fetten
bäumen
ich habe auch noch gesehen was waren
dann noch etwas war hin noch irgendwo
ihr drittes tolles und wasserqualität so
sieht auch richtig er genau der zeitung
ich weiß gar nicht ob der allgemeinen
weit wegziehen wollen oder ob wir direkt
hier bleiben wer guckt jetzt mal wir
haben eine menge fläche hier wo wir was
bauen können also das heim glück allein
so ja also ein fall für die anreise ist
jetzt einfach kraft aus direkt in
walldorf ist aber du hast ist dass die
diese mod allgemein die app bietet so
viele möglichkeiten
ach so freunde dass einzelne jason ein
also leute ich werde das jeden zweiten
tag hochladen und dann kriegt ihr in
zwei akten schauen dann immer abwechseln
mit the beast und um gespielt vielleicht
auch noch aufnehmen wir wissen es noch
nicht so genommen guck mal hier sind
jetzt mal karotten alles da können jetzt
erst mal wissen wollen also die auch die
runde jetzt noch nicht auf
aber nachdem ihr eure tipps eure hilfe
und themenvorschläge in die kommentare
schrieb macht und genau zehn bausteinen
richtig schön umsetzen können werden wir
dann gucken
eine kuh dann werden wir gucken was aber
was wir quatschen können und dann uns
müssen damit beschäftigen und ich hoffe
mal das wird gut weil ich ankommen
positive bewertungen wäre herrlich ich
hasse das wort positive bewertungen sind
immer gern gesehen also guckt man die
hier sich so einen blog ich hab so
selten ist der gar nicht auch hier sind
also ich find dich einmal abbauen
das ist ja eine spitzhacke kräften dass
es eine spezielle ich finds also ich
ganz euch sagen also reichlich das holz
guck dir das mal an hast du das schon
gesehen
nee nee das kann ich nicht was ich
machen ich baue mir erstmal weiter das
holz ist auch anders ich glaube damals
für hühner seine leger ach doch mal ein
bienenhaus das klingt mal richtig drauf
thema richtig drauf mein gott ein aldi
gewinnen haus ach so kommandant steht
auch ohne oma ist also steffen ohne
exzesse kinostart access and i want to
break für maschinen tablet restricted
stilles wasser habe ich endlich
deutschland bereich deutschen ich habe
da drin
also ich hab das doch ok warte vogel
wusstest du schon ein komplettes set im
care kleidung schützt nicht vor allen
negativen effekten so wahrscheinlich
wenn wir das handy kaputt machen kabine
raus oder so oder honig nehmen also mit
dem finger davon bleiben okay wir
versuchen wir haben gesagt wir wollen
erstmal jetzt ein bisschen und zu müssen
hier mit beschäftigen und mit normal was
bauen sodass in kirschrot planes also
von einem kirschbaum ok es gibt hier
schon recht ordentlich ich finde also
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen hat noch
nicht wirklich ein großes so ganz
normales let's play projekt einfach so
ein minecraft spell gehabt und ich fand
einfach es gibt einfach schon zu oft und
irgendwie hatte ich so die motivation
dazu conti hat mich jetzt gefragt also
der liebe con crafter kolben ob ich lust
hätte auf vize biest in der monster hier
warte mal in der kirche sind äpfel brot
ein schwert stiefel hose gold spitzhacke
eisen drin ärgerte vastic wird die brust
der ball ja also ich muss auch ganz
recht sein wenn man sich hier umschaut
hinten diese riesige berge des riesigen
bäumen es gibt so richtig so ein
abenteuer gefühl irgendwie hat man
richtig bock hier alles zu erkunden pass
auf das sind giftpilze die könnten
eventuell giftig sein
simon also opfer willst aber ich war
trotzdem sagen dass wir uns irgendwie
hierzu hinbauen in der nähe weil ich
meine ich sehe da vorne da schon wieder
eine höhle da wo ich hin stark dass auch
noch ne höhne alter guck mal bitte da
siehst du das im hintergrund die bäume
ja ich finde da rücken anna bligh
ich hab so box als zwei kunden ja genau
das was ich meine es ist einfach ein
neues spiel was man wartet dann hole ich
mir das ein bisschen holz war ich mir
schon mal so eine art
häußlein jetzt erst mal ganz ruhig du
christ die schönen bäume fällen möchte
einen baum brauche ich um den hausbau
und ich würde sagen dann ziehen wir wo
wollen wir hin ziehen
ich würde nähe von wasser sagen weil ja
wir können einfach hierhin ziehen würde
ich an diesem see hier ist eigentlich
ein verlust
dass du ihn wie dahin geht obwohl lasst
uns nebeneinander und dann können wir
das somit zum tunnel oder so verbinden
und so weiter oder bist du kannst machen
wir dann die sonne wg machen dann machen
wir auch ein übernachtungs party how i
met your mother
ja genau auch übernachtungs partys mit
ganz viel milch und kekse und ganz viele
europa film und kündigt ein sterben
genau das ist es was geiles diese könnte
so ein richtiges asia feeling auch
machen mit solchen kirschbäume und so
ist das wäre auch geil
also soviel möglichkeit also ich freue
mich richtig auf die wache hier sind
sogar diese setzlinge dafür dass sind
braunau herbst setzlinge können produkte
verstehen darunter can't be used 250
euro etwa 1 km verbracht
also nicht weiter dann hast du immer
noch auf englisch auf deutsch
neben das ist wiederum das wird nicht
übersetzt aber ich weiß im sommer ist
wollen wir uns hier irgendwo hin bauen
oder wollen wir darauf die andere seite
des flusses gehen einer dieser orte
weiter sieht auch richtig geil ist ich
will auch gar nicht so festlegen soll
weitergehen das einfach so ein bisschen
gucken dass man hinterher laufen hier
ist ein ganz großes schneebrett schon
hast du mich flüssig oder reggae geht ok
also
doch einfach mal die zu ungefähr sieht
schon krass aus sonneberg auch ich bin
runter gefallen ich will mir so eine
höher gelegene position irgendwie um
mich ein bisschen um zu gucken sage ich
mal sehr bestimmt schon geil ja dann war
ein bisher alles was hier ist das oder
schwer sondern so ein komischer blog
heißt das dass wir einfach ab ich mache
dir da wartet dann steht auch nichts
dran an den start
okay ich bin bei euch laufwerk ist auf
weg denn mein limit der wird sich mit
den besten anlegen
nein nichts passiert ok ja da war nichts
drin deswegen sagt ihr zu altern
brauchst du einfach ab wir haben
bestimmt einfach irgendwas jetzt falsch
gemacht werden jetzt das komplette ist
schon verpackt hier ja alles spielt
damit heraus dass herbst rauch komische
sachen ich will nicht krieg ich will
dass ich will es probieren story totale
oder so das war mein presse
das ist mein motto dieses wenn er einen
knopf an das ist mein motto oh warte da
sieht geil aus ist richtig geil dass man
bald folgen
hier sind dieser kleine see du bewegst
dich bei mir noch so ein bisschen
stockend stockend ja aber ich weiß nicht
ob das los wenn auch ein bisschen
stocken aber älter dass das sehr geil
die aus der see und vor allem da vorne
diese diese komische grad allerdings
aber die schafe draufstehen alles
schnell sehr geil aus und schon sagen
jetzt eine höhle nicht rein da ist der
lässt apple sind man kann hier schon
wieder so ein komischer warte ich wollte
es ja vorhin schon machen ich mache mir
jetzt mal in crafting table und da
machen uns mal eben ganz kurz ich habe
ja schon eine spitzhacke fällt auf was
okay was ist das ein grünes herz oder
einsatz sind das sind zu diamanten oder
alter guckt jetzt mal bitte was ist das
da kann man drauf den hatte ich vor dass
mappus weg das kaputt macht nein du hast
management chris auch ein schwert oder
hinter den ständer wenn erwartet
schaffst du das ohne rüstung
nein so was was brummt hier so kraft
dieser in am ende zu devil auto hast das
ja hat sind die 1911 fakt ist dass laut
heftig dass man das mal artig gibt immer
ganz kurzen kräftigen tritten nacht
müssen wir schon wartet lasst uns mal
kurz schafe dann könne es eventuell bett
machen
er ist sehr gut wart ihr da oben sind
noch scharf auf diesem komischen links
drauf oder web n einfach dabei dem npc
dörfer den mittelstand genau das dial up
pant warte gilt auch ein paar schafe
japan also ich hab drei wolle
ich bin für dich mit den stockenden
falls es den ausnahmestatus austria bis
zum nächsten mal auch hin
das passt schon so ich habe für dich
drei wolle kommt dann das einfach mal
ganz schnell zurück zum im pc dorf
laufen wobei mir ist hier ganz komischer
fehler in der welt anelka schon wieder
nur dass ich konnte das gerade alles
sehen das ja manchmal dass da einfach
die welt nicht geladen wird aber die
ärzte sieht man dann irgendwie schon
und bei mir weil er gerade lava zu sehen
und zehn milliarden verschiedene arten
von ärzten alter sind wie viele schafe
ach du scheiße ich hab mich verlaufen wo
bist du bist du ja im wald und zombie
bank wo bist du bist du ich bin in summe
biom gelaufen in den browsern die
prionen jetzt kommt die knusperhexe die
wirklich finden
halder handy kann man so vom kurs
abkommt
ich weiß überhaupt nicht so jetzt will
ich versuchte weg zu finden so traurig
weil ich so ungefähr war das war wartet
das war in richtung in richtung 1 also
in richtung west
oh mein gott ich habe angst ist dunkel
und ich bin im wald und mir ist kalt und
ich habe giftpilze dabei die oder oder
findest du den weg zurück zu dem
komischen seh ich bin hier in diesen
ganzen zwischen diesen ganzen chor
spielten wollen da wo wir eben manchmal
will ich auch findest du den weg zurück
zudem zu dem see oder so ich versuch's
ich versuche mich verbindet schon wo
bist du denn gerade mich erstmal bin
gerade direkt am see und ich sehe hier
gerade ein krieg und ich hoffe dass nun
mal nicht dass exportiert und der sache
wird hass gehört dann bis auf weiteres
vom rest keine ahnung gestand schreibt
man wurde minimap haben wir oben rechts
ist er automatisch dabei ich bin bei
minus 2 -12
es ist gar nicht so weit weg wartet dann
ich doch mal kurz zu sehen - 2 ich bin
schon wieder - 20 - 20 lasst uns mal bei
0 0 treffen bitte 20.000 nbc ente 00 uhr
starten wir durch die gegend ich hätte
heute auch noch nicht fertig bist du
hier
ich beschütze ist als zombies jetzt
kommt kommt kommt bei dich darauf lauf
lauf lauf lauf
ja ich muss mein renn renn renn
kommissare die erste nacht überleben das
allerwichtigste
haha ich bin ihm die stadt mit dem
weiterkommen einfach hinter mir steht
aber warum
ach so und jetzt jetzt nicht dass wieder
alle denken hey that's why i und
gespielt hat eine freundin und mein ich
bin ich will das gar nicht sein
also ich habe wirklich freuen das ist
ungewöhnlich für ein game aber ich
gehöre ihr könnt euch auf einem kanal
überzeugt ist so oder so nennt man dahin
sind auch ein skelett und zombie
ob wir nur willkommen neben ihnen leben
ich kann nicht mehr laufen
mein gott ich guckte er nicht an tu ich
erwarte ich helfe dir mit dem spread
haben einfach auf einfach gott ich kann
ich will auf das winterdorf spielaufbau
erlaubt brachte dir schonmal einbettung
irgendwie sowas so knopp sind denn das
schwert zombie hinter die rente bis zu
niemandem respekt
ich bin zum lied auch heute denke ich
war einer von ihnen war so aussieht die
klopfen an die tür das hat sich das
gerät allerdings können rennen dieser
reine hier echt ich bin es im haus
dritte theorie zu und schießt wochen
will ich ja bitte schließt michael fitz
ist auch aus den willicher euro was ein
zug wartete dass entweder der alten
konkurs gehen drin denn alten dann wird
ihr wohnen einfach erstmal oder es ist
schon krass oder teenager mit 2 also der
hand gesagt er heißt rüdiger hier
billiger weil wir also ich würde jetzt
hinzufügen
herr rüdiger wie geht's aus geboxt
politik das war nicht extra wartet
machte mir eben bett
du hast die wahl oder oder solche rolle
geben ich habe alles sicher ob alles
okay dann können wir direkt schon
unseren ponys setzen lassen darf ich
weniger töten der häftling bisschen so
wie oder schiebt ihn einfacher weg
irgendwie hier mal geschieht immer
weggesperrt nämlich setzen haben so ein
doppelbett das wird richtig romantisch
ich krieg das hier nicht weg gesetzt
ehrlich ist einfach der jedoch
scheiterte geht nicht doch die richtige
bett liegt in ruhiger drin
es ist mir ganz egal rüdiger will auch
nur weil man zu kuscheln ok mit guten
neu erlebt hast du gut geschlafen
warte mal ich habe hier die ganzen
sachen abgebaut stimmt jetzt am design
panoramafenster okay ich gehe mal eben
zu diesem auch gut dass dieses villa
dorf ist selbst recht verloren ist es
geht mal
ich gehe mal hier irgendwo essen suchen
kann mir da nicht irgendwas rausnehmen
schoko wabe umwandelten
sie sollten einfach rausnehmen und ein
brunnen warte ich töte ihn ein zombie
will ist im brunnen javascript ein
wasserexperte jetzt erstmal nicht
schlimm so krebstod villiger habe ich
habe ich selber tommy villagers auf den
erste er selten gesehen so was ich mache
mal kurz den ausgang ganzen items die da
drin sind doch gott ist das geht das tor
und teil gibt's möhren braucht es werden
vermehrt wieder zu bauen
irgendwie stört mich dass das da im
inventar über aluminium sind so alles
drin ist kann dass sich alle müssen oder
rücken dann geht das weg was du musste
und dann drücken dann ist das weg ach ja
oft habe ich gemacht
gut dann haben es auch weg ja und ich
würde sagen das war's dann erstmal für
die erste folge die fackeln hier sind
immer noch komisch plätze die man eben
richtig daran übrigens gibt es ja auch
noch kerzen und fackeln also ein
unterschied irgendwie okay kabinen haben
und die haben wachsen ausmachen oder so
genau
glaub ich könnte einfach genau wo ich
keine ahnung von aston villa wird von
mir
nee ich hab ich habe keinen hunger weise
ich hab was sie etwa ich habe ich
verpasst jetzt kohle übrigens also ich
würd dann erst mal sagen das war's für
die erste folge
wir wären euch sehr verbunden wenn wir
uns in die kommentare schreibt was ihr
so alles bei vize biest wird
beziehungsweise uns das ein bisschen
beibringen könnte nachdem ob ich den
geht ist was wir meinen dann können wir
uns auch themen in die kommentare
schreiben und allgemein positive
bewertungen sind immer gern gesehen ja
wenn es euch gefallen hatte wenn es euch
gefallen hat natürlich ja also ich fand
die erst volks und entspannt für krieger
trifft jeden fall sehr geil also wir
können schon mal sondern ein
klitzekleines fazit ziehen
und zwar fand ich die erste volk bisher
richtig richtig hammer weil wir einfach
sofort so richtig hammer sachen entdeckt
haben vor allem weil wir uns das vorher
nicht so wirklich lange angeguckt haben
und wenn du so ein bisschen was
durchgelesen worüber das eventuell
handeln könnte aber war ich verliere
kommt ins leben und muss ich weiß und
die sache ist einfach die dass das
wahrscheinlich richtig geil wird wir
werden wahrscheinlich nicht alles
ausprobieren können weil das so und
umfangreich ist es wirklich schaffen
können im normalen let's play aber wir
versuchen es natürlich und wir versuchen
euch das zu weit ist nur eben geht
irgendwie mit beizubringen sage ich mal
bzw ich das irgendwie näher zu bringen
und euch dazu unterhalten ich das nicht
schön gesagt du hast du wirklich einfach
weiß was er wollte mich vor deiner
sprache sprache ja also natürlich sagen
kann wir die karotten endlich wieder
irgendwie an pflanzen oder sowie das
weiß ich genau
doch einfach darauf einfach dorfrocker
wird von wirkaufens naja also die alles
schon gesagt schreibt in die kommentare
und bewertet das video wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ja das war's mit
ungespielt alle links wenn ihr das auch
spielen wollt sind in der beschreibung
und dann sehen wir uns übermorgen in der
zweiten folge richtig und schoss